Ruby had been groomed sexually abused as
a 12-year-old then a 13-year-old she was
made pregnant when she was just 13 by
one of the gang of abusers And yet when
she was dropped from that job in
2012 just before the trial the Barrister
realized that without her evidence they
could not run that trial because her
evidence was Central to the case so she
was no longer a victim or a witness and
it was too late to bring her on board
for that the only other way of
introducing her evidence into a court of
law was if she was an offender so they
secretly added her to the indictment as
one of the gang of abusers she did not
know she was not arrested she was not
cautioned she had no legal
representation she didn't know until 2
years later when I resigned from the
police and went and told her what had
been said about her in court and as a
result of what was said about her in
court Social Services were trying to
take her children away from her by
saying she was a pedophile now you're
looking shocked I am still shocked to
this day that that is possible in the UK
because if you can be accused of being a
murderer or a pedophile and you are not
made aware you are not given an
opportunity to defend yourself that for
me goes against every single thing that
I
belied happened but that I swear on my
children's life that that is exactly
what has happened in this case and I am
trying to raise awareness that this goes
on in the UK today and furthermore the
CPS still are saying that they were
justified in making that decision and
that they would do it again if it was
convenient what y they will still not
acknowledge that that was wrong and I am
fighting still because to me it goes
against everything even the Yorkshire
Ripper is entitled to a defense this
young girl was was secretly described as
a pedophile she is not she was a victim
of a grooming gang and so this Injustice
still drives me forward because these
are the cases that I do know that's why
the foundation is so important because
victims and survivors come to us today
telling us of current failures of
current injustices and we fight for them
within the system so it's still a
massive problem but um it you know it
shocked me and and it still shocks me um
and
actually it it makes me feel
I I think I was exploited as well if I'm
honest you know I join the police to do
good and yet they are the worst things
that I have ever
seen anybody do to a vulnerable person
and that was done with the full
knowledge and backing and authority of
Chief constables and the CPS and that's
kind of what keeps me going
really